when you have a emergency trauma
situation blood flow can kill a person
much faster than if he lacks oxygen the
first thing you do is touch everywhere
to see if he's bleeding is there is it
wet anywhere and you address all
tourniquets first before you even apply
CPR that's how important it is because
you can bleed out like that in gun
communities when they have like these
self-defense classes if that's truly
what you believe in that the Second
Amendment is also a life-saving device
for as many guns that you have you
should have almost like five to ten
times the amount of tourniquets like for
example like one really unfortunate
event is the shooting in Vegas if every
person that had a gun had five
tourniquets on them imagine how many
lives could have been saved if that's
the goal the fake people they just want
an excuse to go Rambo where's The
Gunshot come from I'll blast them well
the if you're going to be way more
productive if you take care of the
casualties around you well what about
the video of Dan Bilzerian running to
his car to get his gun that's
counterproductive probably yeah he's
like oh someone's shooting I'm gonna go
get my gun tourniquet gun